déjà nous commençons à vivre dans un
monde chacun de nos pas sera guidée par
un oeil électronique la surveillance des
rames de métro par la télévision
inaugurée sur la ligne de sow va se
généraliser dans les années à venir
milieu des années 60
l'utilisation de la vidéosurveillance
commence à se répandre en france
principalement dans les lieux ouverts au
public comme les commerces et les gares
l'objectif assurer la sécurité des
usagers
ici en 1973 à la station de rer charles
de gaulle-etoile 70 caméra surveillait
le flot continu des voyageurs lorsque
vous constatant quelque chose d'anormal
dans la station un attroupement une
utilisation normale les escaliers
mécaniques ou des installations nous
demandant au chef de poste qui est
l'agent mobile de se déplacer vers le
point de l'incident et de voir
exactement ce qu'il se passe les caméras
se multiplient aussi au sens des
magasins un moyen efficace de dissuader
les voleurs et de les prendre parfois en
flagrant délit dans le magasin où l'on
dispose de deux caméras de télévision
qui sont disposés un peu dans chaque
coin de manière à pouvoir surveiller
tout l'intérêt du banc lorrain voyez ce
jeune homme il a l'air louche voyez il
regarde à gauche qu'à droite s'il ne
voit personne s'ils vont pas de
surveillants voyez-y tend le bras il
ouvre le tiroir le cas par une demande
combien de personnes arrêtées vous par
jour ou par semaine selon vos
statistiques on arrête en moyenne ne
dizaines de personnes par jour
à la fin des années 70 les sociétés
d'autoroutes sait qu'il peut aussi de
caméras pour surveiller le trafic
un dispositif que la mairie de creil
dans l'oise refusé d'adopter au nom des
libertés individuelles
il est certain qu'au camp qui est un
gros trafic on n'aperçoit pas ce qui se
passe mais quand la circulation est très
très faible
les caméras aperçoivent les personnes
dans les voitures peuvent surveiller une
personne tout particulièrement et je
pense que c'est peut-être là ce qui a
poussé les collègues à refuser ce projet
face à cette question des libertés
individuelles la loi informatique et
libertés est adopté à l'assemblée en
1978 elle offre un premier cadre à
l'utilisation de la vidéosurveillance et
instaure la cnil la commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés
[Musique]